- So you love Loretta Lynn?
Did you love her growing up?
- I love Loretta Lynn.
- Me too.
- I really did.
And I loved her growing up.
And I grew up on country music,
traditional country music.
Like, 'Three Chords And The Truth',
tin plated steel guitar kind of country.
- Yes, that's my favorite.
- And, me too.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And so I lived in
Nashville a couple of times.
And, as a matter of fact,
I think we might have talked about this,
you guys will find this surprising.
At one time, when I was 15
and hanging out in Nashville,
hanging out in bars, which
I shouldn't have been doing.
But I was already like 6'
4", 220 with a mustache.
I had a dream,
that my dream was I was
gonna be a country singer.
- Oh, we had this talk.
- Yeah.
- Yup.
- And that was my dream.
So what I used to do is, and
I had no money at that time.
And I used to, that's where
all the country bars are at,
and they're all like
dive bars, as you know.
- Yeah, love.
- And I would kind of like
walk the streets and be like,
♪ I kicked the habit ♪
♪ Smoking back something ♪
(audience gasping)
- Hoping that someone.
- Someone would be like, oh hark!
- Someone would be like,
oh, what do you do?
You should come and sing.
But then, it didn't happen for me.
But I love Loretta.
I love country.
And thank you for singing that with me.
- Oh my God!
I was so excited.
(audience cheering)
We literally like ran upstairs yesterday
and I was like, we gotta make this happen!
I love this song.
I love her.
There were so many songs
you could pick from.
But speaking of country music.
So I hear you recently went
back to the trailer park,
that you used to live in,
like when you were a teenager.
Was that, is it?
I kind of like going
back to my beginnings,
cause it's like it keeps it like fresh,
that reminder of man, I had
a big dream and it worked.
You know?
- Yeah.
- I, that was, it was real special for me.
So two things.
I, when I was 15, we were.
Well we were evicted off
the island in Hawaii.
We couldn't pay rent, so we were evicted.
I got sent to Nashville
to live with my dad.
Plans change, as they do.
And I was then sent to live
with a guy who I didn't know
in a little motel room in Nashville.
- That doesn't sound shady.
- No, it sucked.
- Yeah.
- But, you gotta do what you gotta do.
What you're told to do, at least, at 15.
- Yeah.
- So his name was Bruno, Downtown Bruno.
Then, when I broke into pro wrestling,
before I got to the WWE,
I had to hit the road.
Like I'm sure with you too as well,
where before that I wrestled
in a small promotion
where we were wrestling at flea markets,
and used car dealerships.
You do what you gotta do.
- My first time I ever
sang professionally was
at a wrestling match.
It was the 'National Anthem'.
- Oh, wow, see, so.
- I had no idea what I was walking into,
and I wore a really fancy black dress.
And it was like, this was wrong.
I shouldn't have done this.
- This was wrong.
But the voice was right.
- It was fine.
(laughing)
I was very nervous, but it was low key.
Not like WWE, it was like,
yeah, yeah.
- No, no, no, yes.
I mean, we would again,
flea markets and state fairs
is where I started.
So then I went back and I didn't again,
I didn't have a place to live
cause I didn't have any money.
And this guy, Bruno, put me in his place
and he had a little trailer.
So, I recently went back after
all these years with Bruno,
and I went back to this trailer.
This trailer park, actually
in walls, Mississippi.
- Yeah.
- And it was a really moving
moment cause it's like
all that stuff comes back to
you where it was struggle,
and it was uncertainty,
and what's gonna happen,
and is this my life?
- Do you think that
that drives you though?
I feel like it drove me
to like kind of break out
and do something bigger.
I knew that I was capable of.
- Yes.
- I feel like that
struggle kind of helped.
- Yes, Kelly.
A hundred percent.
And I, like you, I'm
sure like a lot of us,
I keep that right here in
the forefront of my mind.
- Amen.
- Like I don't forget that.
- Yeah.
- And that drives me.
Cause to me I'm just
- It makes you're appreciative.
- Yeah, and so grateful.
Because it can all go away like that.
So stay grounded and stay humble.
- Yeah.
I'm glad you got that experience.
(audience cheering)
That's cool.
- It was amazing.
- Yeah.
- By the way, that trailer,
that little trailer,
has not changed one bit.
It's the exact same trailer.
- Oh, wow!
- Small, kind of like
- Like walking into your past.
That's crazy.
- It was unbelievable, yeah.